[Music]
why am i
just uh
out of everything
[Laughter]
already i i feel like i'm out of uh
a lot of spoons i'm out of uh energy
i'm out of i don't know
a lot of strength to open this i hope
not
oh for god's sake that's just
oh that's just freaking perfect
[Laughter]
ha ha
that's better how's everybody doing
tonight
oh well welcome aka watch nice to have
you here always nice to have new people
around
uh i don't have a lot of spoons either
after all this heat that's
fair carolyn i've like i've seen the
news about what it's like over there
[Music]
hello nods like it's a tuesday how
exactly does a tuesday nod
differ from any other day of the week
i'm now curious
i'm out of them too all of them i'm on
the verge of a dorothy's bornak moment
we should all be so lucky to be that
coherently
snarky when we snap
to either get ice cream or commit a
felony i'll decide in the car
yeah that that is kind of where things
are at
how would you describe each of your
subscribers in one word
i do not ha i do not have the bandwidth
for a question like that don't ask me to
process
that's not that's that's not happening
tonight
tonight needs to be i'm not saying it
needs to be surface level questions but
it needs to be something that i can dive
into without having to think too hard
about it so that i can
i can just run on semi-autopilot that's
tonight's stream
uh do not take that as me not thinking
you folks are worth the effort
you're worth all the effort and love in
the world i just only have so much to
give and it may be less than you deserve
but we're here we're trying we're doing
a thing
i don't know what this thing is but we
are doing it
so do it what's the worst day of the
week i'm debating thursdays because i
can never get the hang of them
uh yes that uh that is accurate i see it
like at this point
when you work from home and work for
yourself your
days bleed together in a way that
you know going to uh going to an office
job a monday to
friday thing just doesn't do the
distinction between days
becomes very indistinct if i didn't have
certain things that i do on certain days
i would lose
all sense of time like you know new
video goes up saturday for the next few
weeks i've got
new loki on wednesdays um
normally i stream on twitch on
wednesdays i need to clear my schedule
on that because i'm not going to be able
to do that the next two weeks which is
part of why i like
i'm i'm preemptively exhausted
um also reactively exhausted i'm
exhausted for multiple reasons
the first being that like i spent the
last five days doing a crap
ton of driving around and i did get some
relaxing in
i am happy to say that but like a lot a
lot
of uh of driving was going on
uh in a lot of different um parts of
several states and that was exhausting
and
i've i'm gonna be doing that again
actually starting tomorrow and then
i'll have to spend about a week trying
desperately to get ahead of my workload
because i've got a heck of a lot more
driving to do
next week and it's not worth going into
why
um all of this is going on and like
nothing's wrong
i'm fine i'm not and there's no massive
life change going on
i'm not like i'm not moving or anything
like that it's just
stu things just are happening rapid fire
one after the other and it's like
just stop ah
and then you add the heat on top of that
and it doesn't help and yes i understand
it's way worse on uh
on the west coast right now so
sympathies do you like winnie the pooh
the poo never did much for me i mean
it's vaguely pleasant
nods of the week are taught in british
school
it varies the amount of eye contact and
what degrees your neck bends forward so
see if that's the case i'm curious as to
how the british cut loose and what a
saturday nod looks like
like i i would imagine like a tuesday
would be
fairly terse something but like a
saturday would be like
[Music]
but then again that's me being not uh
not properly british by your standards
i'm sure
british by heritage but not by a
lifestyle
as a delivery driver i know your pain i
oh
a friend of mine's married to a delivery
driver he works i think it's ups
um but this this pandemic has been a
nightmare because he's just had
so much work to do uh
i watched winnie the pooh last month and
i legit cried the whole movie oh
it's so pure and innocent that this
cynical jerk
just couldn't stop crying yeah
yeah that happens a saturday not as a
head crashed on a pub table
i support that agenda
uh cheers to that
i imagine a saturday nod being like
professor mcgonagall
being giddy when she finally gets to use
the statue of life spell
uh i don't know what that was what am i
doing what are you doing
why are you watching what is going on
what are things
words why don't know
uh my spouse fixes appliances she's been
busy all
pandemic yeah that would do it too uh
any thoughts on the new foundation
trailer
i forgot it dropped and i haven't
watched it um
i still don't know about how viable that
is
at least has something interesting the
thing is like asimov
is his writing is heady
and dry like let me put it this way
while the degree
to which they screwed it up was
impressive it was not
shocking that something called irobot
was turned into a
brainless action movie because like
trying to actually translate asimov
straight just it's not cinematic
what are your thoughts on the crow 1994
the crow is possibly the most
1994 piece of media that exists and i
kind of love it for that
oh uh john vinyls van als
fennels i don't know but you get a heart
you get a heart my friend
um i didn't ow i didn't explain
interactivity on the oh
god i'm off to a to a terrible start
so um super chats get you a heart and my
um my undying gratitude
and um and also of course i will
it guarantees i will read your comment
and or answer your question
as applicable i try and keep up with the
chat otherwise but i don't make any
promises uh short of that
so uh what is your favorite musical by
lynn
arens and steven uh flaherty ragtime
once on this island glorious ones
anastasia
seussical the only ones of those that i
know
is once on this island actually no i do
know seussical
it's okay i actually like once on this
island a lot
um that's a really really good show
um so uh that's easily gonna take the
the top spot for me out of out of those
options
um like this is embarrassing
because like there's part of me now as
an adult like
should we have put that on but like when
i was like 20
um i was in uh like a community theater
production of that
uh and it was a lot of fun and i was i'm
i'm glad to have had that experience but
you know it was done in vermont so we
were all
really white and like i know
i know that like there is a version of
the script there is an alternate version
of the script for
something other than an all black cast
so it's like it is accounted for
and like it is permitted
in terms of getting the license to do it
and everything else but at the same time
like i'm looking back at that going
i'm not sure we should have done that
ah it was it was a fun show though
oh castillo there's a heart for you
i'm very sorry to hear you had a bad day
just want a heart because you had a bad
day today
i hope that however much time you have
left in the day
treats you better and more importantly
tomorrow is a new day and i hope for the
best for you then
uh have you heard of the big finnish
short story competition
i have i've heard of it in the past and
like
you know maybe um
[Music]
maybe some year when i'm not um
in the middle of trying to publish my
own well trying i should see
publishing my own damn novel um
maybe i'll i'll even throw something in
to compete with that but um yeah
it's it's one of those things that like
i'm so buried in work the idea of
actually participating
is just i i can barely wrap my head
around it
um oh thomas johnson no comment but just
uh just dropped a super chat which is
wonderful and greatly appreciated you
get a heart
um
thanks also i can relate to your
experience i played a chinese character
in thoroughly
uh modern millie possible native
american and fantastics yeah
like it's the kind of thing again it was
20 years ago
i was 20 years old it was done in
vermont like
i don't think anyone would judge us too
much at the time but like
i certainly wouldn't do it now um any
thoughts on good omens being confirmed
for season two okay so when i first saw
that announcement
um because someone tagged me in it on uh
on twitter uh and when i first saw that
announcement
i got exceedingly nervous
um because you know the the first one
it pulled so i mean like it did some
original stuff too don't get me wrong
but it pulled so much from the original
book
that even knowing that there were ideas
and
things sketched out for possible sequels
it terrified me as an idea especially
because
previously after show running the first
season
neil gaiman said he's not going to do
something like that again
and that he did it to basically shepherd
and
guard the work of his dear friend terry
pratchett
now he is being listed and i think
as a co-show runner so it looks like
he's taking on a little less
responsibility
but neil gaiman being directly involved
is the one and only thing that has me
cautiously optimistic as opposed to
flatly terrified
because i do not want this to be another
american gods situation
which had a phenomenal first season and
then went
[Music]
in its second season
the box office movie that was number one
on your 10th birthday the song that was
number one on your seventh on the
broadway show that won best musical and
your 10th birthday defines 2021 for you
i'm not looking any of that up
so that requires too much effort
and work so no uh have you got any
classic hoo reviews lined up anytime
soon
hopefully next month like i this is what
part of is what's really frustrating
about all this crap
and like how i said i've been i've got
all this driving and i've got all this
other stuff
um going on and
it's preventing me from catching up i'm
not
like i'm still getting out on time the
stuff that i
you know i normally get out the saturday
videos i've kept up with loki
um you know the podcasts and and all of
that but like i'm not
catching up on all this other freaking
backlog which is driving me up
the wall i just wanna i just
[Music]
i just want to get a head
that is all i want and i can't
seem to do it
it's really starting to drive me crazy
because
every time i think i might
have a uh a chance or a plan or it looks
like things have
fallen in such a way that um
that they'll allow me to get ahead
something goes horribly wrong
and not not necessarily bad but like
something that i forgot to account for
kicks in or that i planned
ages ago or that like is an opportunity
i can't miss or
is just something that i need to
participate in and
and like might have nothing to do with
work or anything else but like
this demands my attention now and so i
can't
ah
oh that's good water
so what do we got we got more super
chats
uh thomas johnson came in again you get
another heart my friend i watched doctor
who
demon's story and then the mass singer
for the first time
that was my weird night in keeping
awesome beer
thank you and thank you for the hearts
back that is um
that is an interesting double header uh
you set up for yourself there
i um i've yet to see the demons
and i don't really have much interest in
shows like the mass singer i know what
it is
um and it's kind of like okay
uh
ben i'm not even gonna read that out
loud
because and i say this with love [ __ ]
you
even as a joke even as a joke
[ __ ] you oh
all right it's a purple raider you get a
heart uh what do you think of power
rangers
power rangers came in and i was just uh
like i watched
a little bit of the first season like
mainly out of
boredom but i was a little too old for
it
it's the kind of thing that a lot of
friends who i had their younger siblings
got into it
uh sort of where that landed timing-wise
um i was just a touch tool it's one of
those things i've always been aware of
but like
other than a handful of episodes in the
first season um
i never really watched much
oh god that's so
good
[Music]
if you had to watch a broadway musical
every day for the rest of the year which
one would you choose
um next to normal
oh new type uh jb lee
you get a heart i'm vaguely singy today
and i don't
know why is the doctor having a lot of
interest
really controversial anymore because
back in the day love interest felt
like a taboo uh do the 90s tv movie
pilot
um it has become
uh certainly less taboo for the doctor
to show
that kind of affection but
let me put it this way i think and i
think this would be
um an issue not even
um like even if this happened with
someone other than
chibnall so like if this happened no
matter who it was
this would cause a fan uprising if
um and like again to be clear if this
happens
and people outcry over it it's just
because of the inherent thing if they
decided to
make explicitly for
the run of a show the doctor and the
companion a romantic couple
not building towards a relationship like
with
rose not one pining after the other
like with martha not a an occasionally
appearing character like river
but the actual main companion and the
doctor
a couple canonically like for the run of
a series
i think you would still get fans going
up in arms so
while the general idea of the doctor
being
affectionate and having those kinds of
feelings in general is not the same kind
of taboo it used to be
i think there are still ways to over
step and over push it
so and i say that as someone who has
zero interest in the idea that the
doctor even has a love life
like i i don't care
so hard it is a
it is a deep and unabiding
well of disinterest in that
very idea on my part
uh what are your top three favorite
comic book
uh runs okay so
i am going to um
i need to put an asterisk on one of
these
and state flat out
uh enjoyment of a work is not
endorsement of a person and no that's
not me saying separate the artist from
the art because
i've done whole videos saying that you
can't do that but i am saying that
one of these i have not
i don't have a replacement for and so
at this point in time it's gonna make my
top three even though i very
badly want to be able to name something
else at this particular point because of
the
writer involved like in that way it's a
little bit how
basically until things like nanette and
now inside happened
it really irritated the [ __ ] out of me
that i could not think of a
better comedy special like as a complete
package than bill cosby's himself
um and it was kind of a relief to
experience things that i did
legitimately think were better and so i
didn't have to keep
acknowledging uh that thing anymore
but anyways back to the original
question uh
neil gaiman sandman here's the one with
the asterix
uh trans metropolitan which is by warren
ellis
um so i am not encouraging the
purchasing of it
i already own the full run um and to be
fair on that one i also have not re-read
it in a long time and it may not have
aged as well as i think it did
but i'm also not in a headspace right
now where i feel like
i can give it a fair shake trying to
reread it or i would be able to
um divorce my
uh my current issues with the writer
from it so i wouldn't try anyways
but at some point if i if i ever get
comfortable enough
to revisit that material i would not be
surprised to find out it has not aged as
well as i would have liked it to
anyways and then the other one is uh the
max
sam keith the max i actually
so hot take i actually think the
animated series is slightly better
not because it did any major changes i
actually think that story works
better in an animated presentation than
still images i i just think it does
okay
um oh ak watch thank you very much
for the super chat you get a heart
um i have always hoped to see the doctor
and the master in a love relationship
and they get messed with all seasoned
by the valley heart i don't folks know
who that is i know who the valley yard
is
um
i would be really
happy to see
the actual relationship between the
doctor
the master explorer you know beyond the
adversarial nature of it like and that's
one in my mind that is
that is the biggest loss of capaldi not
doing one more series because what what
i
want what my what my heart wants and
wanted then and will always want and
will never have
is a full series of doctor who
where missy is the companion to
capaldi's doctor
and for me again with my
issues and reservations around
portraying the doctor as that kind of
romantic anyway i wouldn't necessarily
want it to be romantic but i would
want that relationship to be further
explored and further
elaborated on further delved into and it
really does feel like a shame that it
didn't happen and
i don't if it ever does it's not going
to be for a while because i
don't think dejuan's master is going to
be able to pivot in a way that
anything other than a excuse me complete
harsh adversarial relationship is ever
going to exist between
him and well definitely um
jody whitaker's doctor probably any
doctor and that's not a criticism of his
performance
it's just that the way he has chosen to
portray the master like i don't i don't
see that
evolving into a non-adversarial
relationship
i just don't
i want to see future companions from
another planet or time period andy i
have been saying that
for literally years
and like here's here's what i i do
appreciate
about the uh chibnall whitaker era so
far
they did break from having the
young conventionally attractive um
uh from day england companion in the
sense that we had
two males come two male companions one
of whom was older i actually did
appreciate that
but but
like can we
please please
have someone not from earth not from
modern times
don't care if it's the future don't care
if it's the past
just somebody somebody else
the and i i do understand
that the there is a logistical reason
for why they have earth-based companions
is it helps
justify so many earth-based stories
which they
need to do to keep the budget under
control
because if everything was set on foreign
planets or space stations or sets they
had to
build um or required more working they
couldn't just use locations or existing
sets
from you know just stock modern settings
then
the price tag on the whole thing goes up
i do understand that logistical
issue but i'm just sick
of modern era human companions
really sick of them and i say that
like here's the thing i am more
interested in getting a companion not
from the modern era
than i am of getting one from another
planet because if i'm gonna be
completely honest most of the companions
who came
from worlds other than earth weren't
great
and actually some of the worst ones came
from places other than earth
um but
you know taking from the past
from the future i just do something
shake it up
stop defaulting to modern earth all the
dang time
thoughts on the works of alan moore um
alan moore is very good at what he does
he um
he puts a lot of work alamor doesn't
know how to half-ass anything
um i find some of his stuff overrated i
found league of extraordinary gentlemen
to be pretty overrated
i find watchmen to be frustratingly
nearly
unimpeachable like that's one of those
pieces like it's
irritating how good that is um
[Music]
and as for his other his work on swamp
thing was really interesting
i need to re i've read some of i really
need to read more of promethea
um because i i found some of the
concepts in that
um really interesting
it like that's one thing i will always
give more credit for he is
never uninteresting even at uh
his clunkiest when things aren't landing
there's still going to be good ideas
behind
it so and that's more than you can say
for a lot of
actually i would say for most writers
who have been writing comics for as long
as he have
most of them have started to just
recycle
ideas or have started phoning it in uh
very
um evidently
ah i want to see an earlier regeneration
of the master
face off with a later version of the
doctor the doctor would know what the
master does
before they do and try to stop those
events
um so
i'm into part of that idea because
here's the thing
there is a big enough gap
between you know when the doctor sees
the master that the master has gotten up
to all kinds of things the doctor hasn't
encountered before
i would absolutely be down with the
doctor encountering an earlier version
of the master
but not in a oh i know how these
specific events play out way
but rather in a way that the doctor has
other means to use for knowledge of what
the master's gonna be like
to actually possibly miscalculate
because um you know you could i mean
this
you couldn't really do this but
hypothetically
if you were able to have jody whitaker's
doctor who at this point is used to
dealing with sachita one master
encounter the roger delgado master
if she tried to deal with him the way
she deals with sasha dewan
she would find that oh that actually
doesn't work i've miscalculated and like
i'm i'm
playing against the i'm not playing the
adversary exactly like i thought i was
um and then in addition to that you
could have
her just her knowledge of how the master
operates and possibly find ways of
throwing him off his game
by dropping you know future failures
that he's going to have
pointing out how many times he's going
to just lose
presumably this time too just to throw
him off i think something that would be
interesting i would find it
less interesting if um
if he just if the doctor just flat out
knew how
the specific events in the story were
supposed to play out i would find that
less interesting
um oh new type jb lee another super chat
thank you
thank you so much it's a beating heart i
don't know why
speaking of who how do you feel about
the queer themes and subtext of the
russell t davies era especially it's
been over 10 years since it ended have
they aged well
um well first of all not a lot of it's
subtext
a lot of it's pretty textual
um and for the most part i don't think
they've aged
too badly um
i i i'm hard-pressed to think of too
many things that like flat out it's like
kind of makes me go uh go like that but
um
that element wasn't was never my
favorite part of his
era anyway and like it's funny a lot of
the quintessential
content from davies era
wasn't actually written by him like
captain jack
created by um by moffat
time crash which has the master beard
wife beard joke um written by moffat
you know it's it's actually kind of
interesting to go back and and realize
that um as much as i i think it's
easy to say that it was because of
davies and he certainly fostered an
environment where those sorts of things
were
allowed to fly but um
he he was not the originator for a fair
amount of the
quote-unquote gay content that went on
during his own run
it's it's actually kind of interesting
to think about two questions
what are your favorite stories for the
silmarillion
um i'm about to lose nerd cred i haven't
read the silmarillium properly
i've skimmed it it's even drier than the
lord of the rings is so
pass and do you prefer gilbert and
sullivan or
bertolt brecht i know the name bertolt
brecht i'm gonna have to google
um that though because i'm not coming up
with shows off
i do like me some gilbert and sullivan
so
my inclination
is going to be it's probably going to be
them
but you know what let's give old bertolt
the
uh the benefit of the doubt and actually
look
oh three penny opera okay
okay yeah i know i i'll i like i like
gilbert and sullivan
better i just like
i just like the fun of their stuff
it's just so fast and
rapid fire and there's so much work like
i'm a sucker for word play
i'm i'm a sucker for high-end dad jokes
and that's
basically what gilbert and sullivan are
doing about half the time
uh and it's it's just so it
i remember god i was probably
10 years old 10 or 11
and i saw the mikado performed
and i laughed so much
at that show and like
culturally uh in uh insensitive like i
understand that
it is it is problematic oh um thank you
carowind yes uh john
uh vinyls venals however is pronounced i
did i did
mean to give you a heart for that sorry
about that um thank you thank you
carowind
um but i gilbert and sullivan it's so
sharp and it's so fast and that's what i
love in comedy i love
rapid fire comedy which feels
um it feels like it's starting to come
back
a little bit um but we um
we went through the decade plus
of the um the judd apatow
era of mainstream comedy
which was the death of wit and um
i just love the
i love rapid fire i love i can barely
keep up with these jokes they're
happening so fast
um and they are clever enough that you
have to think about each one they just
are coming
at you like that i love that
so i love pirates of penzance i love the
mikado
it's uh it's really really good stuff
um
so yeah they're easily gonna get it
from me
ah for i am a pirate king you are
off of the pirate king and it is it is a
glorious thing to be a pirate king
uh hopefully i don't get in trouble for
that i don't think that's gonna get
copyright
struck although the uh performance
rights still get held by
somebody i think i don't think that
might be public domain
is it hang on hang on
is gilbert and sullivan in
the public
domain
there it is ah
it is public domain hurrah for the
pirate king
i am the very model of a modern major
general of information vegetable
animal and mineral i know the kings of
england and i quote the fights
historical from marathon to waterloo and
order categorical
okay um there's been so much in the chat
and i do
i don't have it in me to scroll back
there were even questions i was like oh
that's interesting i should
um i should look at that i saw blind
guardian came up
and i don't know the context i love
blind guardian
um thoughts on the highlander reboot is
that still
happening is that still a thing
because it shouldn't be there's my
thoughts um
do you read a mango watch any anime
nothing currently ongoing
um my interest in anime is honestly more
with films than with the series because
the series can be a commitment
um i don't have that time
you need to find doctor who and the
pirates they do a fantastic gilbert
sullivan parody ooh
i color me intrigued six are the
greatest showmen oh
for reasons of um
slagging off as opposed to elevating
problematic historical male figures i'll
go with six
for right now uh
uh doctor who in the pirates was made
for you okay okay i'll
i'll try and remember like people are
gonna have to hit me up on twitter
something to remember because
like i'm hydrating i'm exhausted
we'll see if i remember any of this
chris mcgovern
why did i pronounce it like that i do
not know but you get a heart
you clutch that and hold it
hold it tight in the good times and the
bad
it will lead you on
i love gilbert and sullivan even with
the cultural issues
i just enjoy the music and silly humor
in quotes hms pinafore
uh and trial by jury also rock it i mean
it's all good they just do really
really good stuff uh whenever i listen
to blinding lights i
think of because i know you like that
that is a good song um what do you think
of the sudden
resurgence of love for the prince of
egypt um all that makes me think is
uh dang i suppose i should actually get
around to seeing the damn thing
and no cara i am not drunk
yet
uh when i think of modern major general
i think of cartoon individual by
animaniacs
see for a while um
i would hear modern major general and i
would think of the elements song
which i think is they might be giants
which is just going through all the
elements on the periodic table
[Laughter]
but it's it's that same rhythm and
tune tune it's a lovely tune
what am i doing ah
um during your luke is guilty of
queerbaiting i hissed when you mentioned
rolling you told me that's a natural
reaction at this point it just kind of
is
um just tweeted the link to your twitter
thank you for twitting at me
on on the tweeters much appreciated
um tom
uh lehrer
tom l is elements i think okay possibly
um
thank you ian's standing up for me i am
not
pissed uh
which death of a doctor who cast or crew
member made you the saddest
um see the thing
is uh i think the only one that's really
hit me particularly hard so far uh was
elizabeth sladen
um because of the ones that have
passed away since i've started watching
the show she's
kind of the only one who like i knew her
work
um because you know other ones that have
passed on like
because i've still got so many gaps in
my classic especially because that's
more you know where you're going to get
people passing of of old age
or you know complications related to
that
so she she was that one bummed me out
that said i should probably
be upfront about the fact that i don't
i don't really get depressed by
um
uh by celebrity deaths
i just i the thing
is i connect with work and i'm not i'm
not gonna say i
never do and like i can certainly be
disappointed by
the actions of of celebrities they're
capable of doing that but like
i don't i don't stand
uh real people in a way that would
have it hit that hard i've been
surprised
by celebrity deaths i i'm
hard-pressed to think of any that made
me like truly deeply
sad um
yeah i saw i i don't i don't have the
same reaction
a lot of people um do pish-pished just
sounds irish to me
well kyle it's it's uh it's a red dwarf
um
reference now i'm not gonna mish
mish what you you just said mish you've
only had two pints and you're steaming
no remember i'm totally fine i am not
pissed
um do you have enough thoughts
oh do you have enough thoughts about
kink
and sex as a queer person to do a video
for the vera wild channel
might be interesting for those of us who
aren't educated in that area
phew um i have been
planning for some time
to do a
kink related video on the vera wild
channel
um i have not had the time to
sh because like what i want to do with
it is going to be a much
um more involved shooting process than i
normally
do so i haven't had the time to do that
because like i said i
i can't even get caught up
well like make headway in like catching
up on
mainly stuff for the break room
commissioned reviews um
and all that so i i
every time a new month starts i'm like
this month i'll get to the to the kink
video and i never do
but um my intention with that video is
more to talk about my own
personal relationship with kink
as both a queer person and
actually honestly also somebody with
adhd
upon reflection i was kind of surprised
to
sort of hit on how much my adhd
shapes my relationship with kink
so uh
that'll happen at
some point when
i do not know no promises on that
much more involved shooting process all
that means ben all that means is like
multiple setups wanting to do more
interesting things
with the lighting than i normally do
because normally i just make sure my
face is lit and i go
um i i want to
uh i i want
to do things with that
video that it's just gonna be
more work than is typical and like
more work in a way that isn't usually
how i make more work for myself
generally
if a video involves more work it's
usually going to be on the editing end
and i'm getting used to that i have the
impediment of having an
absolute crap garbage computer that
chugs gravel
trying to render things but i do
uh like i'm used to that uh
sort of increasing the back end the
editing side of things
increasing that workload but um
the uh doing a more elaborate shoot
and more setups and more um
just doing a shoot in a way that it
won't be something that i can just shoot
in a day
um probably is that
is not something i'm used to doing so
uh oh geez people are just going through
just going through
celebrity desks that hit them again most
of these like at most surprised me but i
don't know i think it's just because
a significant part of my brain just goes
you didn't know them
like i know their work and i'm sad to
the extent of oh we're not going to get
any more
from them and i have feeling bad for
um their
uh their loved ones but you know i can't
feel
a personal sense of loss because i
didn't know them personally and that's
not to like say that
you can't feel a personal loss i'm just
saying i don't
i was surprised how much adhd influenced
my relationship with kink me someone
else with adhd huh
so like i'll when i eventually shoot
this video i'll go into
more detail but
um my
relationship with kink is wide reaching
but shallow so
there's um
there there's elements of the
the kink world where you you have people
who like real
this thing this is their thing they
going deep on it they go into
you know you find this a lot with uh
with like with riggers and
rope bunnies and people who like to tie
up and to do the tying and get into
these really elaborate
knots and these uh impressive setups and
you know this gear
i there's no aspect of kink that i am
into enough
to dive in that layer because my brain
won't commit
to one thing that hard but
the flip side of that is i am
[Music]
up for and or into a much
wider range of things
than some because some people like find
find their thing that works for them
and just go all in on that thing
i can't do that my brain doesn't work
that way
so you know
let's see there are several
intersections between neurodivergence
disability and
kink uh tldr processing affects all the
things
uh c also claimed uh
identify not sure what that second bit
means but
yeah it um yes discord on it in just a
minute carowind
yeah the way your brain processes it
it's not that like
i'm not saying my adhd affects
what i have interest in as far as
um sex or kink goes but it does
i do feel very strongly that it impacts
how many things i
have um a passing or fleeting interest
in and the fact that i don't
like go in all on one interest
like i i i make i personally make the
distinction
between a kink and a fetish
in both cases it refers to something
that
is not um typically
part of a quote-unquote
normal sexual encounter it involves
something being brought into play
which is not inherent to
um the act of sex and
i i'm losing viewers talking about this
i'm watching the count go down
oh dear but um
[Music]
the distinction i make between uh kink
and fetish is that
when someone has a fetish
they're not incapable of taking pleasure
in the absence of their fetish but
they're going to
feel that absence it's going to be
slightly less fulfilling for not being
there
kink is not that dependent
when you have a kink it's oh that would
be fun
we can do this but you don't um
you're not as reliant on it you don't
feel its
absence at least not the specific thing
like
if vanilla uh interactions uh
bore you then you might feel the absence
of any kind but like you're not going to
be
um bemoaning the loss of a specific
um thing if if you're just sort of
into kink as opposed to have fetishes or
at least that's sort of my colloquial
um understanding and distinction
whether or not that's helpful i do not
know um anyways i need to hop over the
discord this is your reminder that
um the council of geeks discord is a
thing
that exists and it is an exclusive perk
to
patreon supporters so if you want to get
in on there which not only gets you um
me guaranteed to answer your questions
if you ask them and the discord uh live
stream
channel over there without having to do
super chats but
in addition to that there's a whole
bunch of um channels with various
specific topics and things to talk about
and
lots of cool nifty
people i try to think of a more
elaborate word than people i just landed
on people so people
cool people i like the people they're my
kind of people
okay um
so i i had said uh i had no solid theme
but i plan on i
plan to be hydrating and uh you guys
said well there's your theme insert joke
about being thirsty here
the thirst is real uh so the theme will
be
rambling and doctor who got it yeah
pretty much
um we all know it'll end up going there
and it'll be great ah
all right two live streaming questions
uh given you no longer have the former
day job
have you thought about putting live
streams on at times which are more
accessible
to non-american continent dwellers
um i hadn't uh
part of the reason is that even though i
don't have the
day job anymore i do still try and
structure my own day
um similar to a typical workday i'm not
always great at
adhering to that but i do try
and so i uh that's probably the main
reason i hadn't
thought about doing that um
now that's not to say that i couldn't um
maybe i'll ponder that i'm not it's not
gonna happen anytime soon
because like right now i'm just like too
much crap going on for me to think about
messing with
what have been up to this point fix
things on the schedule
um and then second question as you did
the
picard uh season two trailer reviewer
reminded me that while
overall i liked it i hated what they did
with um icheb
ikeb i don't i don't even remember who
that is
um also with hugh but not so much
uh what is it you most uh what is it you
most disliked fridging of a character
for nothing more than plot motivation
well okay so fridging as i use it
um uh and like i do think i use it
properly so
fridging spawns from the phrase women in
refrigerators coined by gail simone back
before she was an amazing comic book
writer and back when she was just a fan
and she had a blog
and she was noting the tendency of
comic books especially but it's by no
means limited to superhero comics
but she was noticing uh the disturbing
trend of
uh injuring harming or killing
often very brutally female characters
for the explicit purpose of motivating a
man
and it's called women in refrigerators
because what set her off was when the
then current um green lantern kyle
rainer his he came home to find his
girlfriend
dismembered and stuffed into the
refrigerator
and it was a gang gross
um ikeb was the borg child from voyager
oh that's why
i didn't recognize it because i don't
know voyager worth a dang
but um so
yeah fridging is it's a really gross
practice
um now it generally when you
um bring up
the idea of fridging it's it is usually
used in reference to
women being damaged or brutalized or
killed or
raped for the express purposes
of um motivating a man to action
so this was a big part of why i
don't like deadpool 2. they fridge
vanessa in the opening
it's inherent to films and stories like
rob roy and it's it's really
um is really ingrained in a lot of these
stories and that's not to say that
like any trope you can't say flat out
that there has never been
a good use of it
but it's overuse
certainly and especially the way that it
treats
these women not as characters but as
plot points to motivate other people
um especially looked at uh on the whole
as a pattern and
like some even um like really
beloved characters like barbara gordon
in the killing joke
um it's it's really gross
male male characters don't get treated
that way
which is why you generally won't use the
term fridge to refer to
damage to a male character even if it is
to motivate another male character just
because the
the cultural dynamic and the cultural
baggage
isn't the same that's not to say that it
can't also be gross
doing that as well god adding new
nuance on the fly is
[ __ ] annoying
okay
deadpool also wasted the potential of
terry crews and brad pitt
i can't disagree with that because
i thought that joke was kind of
brilliant
that's the thing there's there's one
stretch of
um deadpool 2 that i love and it's
basically the entire x-force thing i
love the
recruiting i love the fact that they
pretty much all die immediately and i
love watching domino's luck superpower
i love watching that play out oh it's
great
it's about the only stretch of the movie
that i think is great but
um i do like i will legitimately say
that
that was good stuff have you seen the
mysterious benedict society on disney
plus
have not even height of it
um i'm still surprised that it wasn't
uh making you watch doctor in distress
that made you finally
say fu to me um
no because that that was just a mildly
annoying
irritant the your insistence on it and
then the thing itself was just
bizarre um but
but like with that gag
where i said that to you earlier in the
stream uh you
poked at trauma my friend you poked at
entertainment based
trauma and you do so at your own peril
ah and that's
that's all the water that there was to
be had in there
ah what are your thoughts on willow
that's a fun movie i grew up on it i
have not rewatched it
in a long time
in a long long time um
but i i did like it i used to watch it
semi regularly as a kid and i know
there's going to be a series on disney
plus and i'm curious
um but
um there are parts like the
when that troll gets zapped and like
his skin kind of peels back and it's
just like this
this gross wet furry ball that the
dragon starts to emerge out of that
oh that did not belong in a pg movie
that's like that was like a legit
body horror movement that was effed up
uh that whole thing i'm re-watching red
dwarf and only fools and horses i
um i've i've gotten a chance to revisit
some red dwarf because i've started
listening to
um the uh
everybody is dead dave podcast um
with adam martin and uh phillip hawkins
and that's a good time
um they're re making an american
werewolf in london what are your
thoughts
why why
what
apology not i hope uh mr buck's lack of
work
starts to heal your entertainment trauma
i'll i tell you
it i don't um
i don't generally
um try to revel in
people's careers stalling but given that
he was
a show runner so it wasn't just like you
know an actor who maybe needs to just be
cast in the right part he was just an
absolutely terrible writer
and show runner and everything he
touched turned to [ __ ]
i'm glad he's not working
i'd like i'm not wishing poverty on him
i'm not hoping he like loses his house
or whatever but i'm just glad he's not
working
just glad he's not working yes i need to
i need to fix the the twitch there will
not be a twitch
stream tomorrow i am i am sorry
um to report but as i've said a few
times across the stream
too much grip there's
too much too too too
too much crap going on in my life
and it's all uh it's all happening
at the same time and it's piling up and
i'm i'm a little stressed i
i'm not i'm not going to lie
um i am mildly stressed and
it's uh annoying
because you know i i try and construct
my work schedule and i try to keep on
top of things enough that
i don't get particularly
stressed but it's happening
right now it's this is the thing
it's the thing that's going on um
it's hard to watch the crow knowing what
happened to brandon lee that's
valid um for me in an odd way i'm not
i don't want to go i'm not gonna say it
makes the movie better because that
would be
a really gross sentiment but
um i will say that
watching it through the lens of knowing
what happened does give it different
meaning so like there there's the point
in it and like this hit
this moment wouldn't have hit me
um without the meta knowledge of of what
happened and that is
there's a point where he becomes
vulnerable towards the end of the movie
and he gets injured and
ernie hudson asked him i i thought you
were invisible
sorry invincible and brandon lee goes
i was and there's something about the
way
he delivers just those two words
and knowing what happened and how
effed up it was it just
hits different you know
uh john vinyls fennels vanals
i'm like i i've committed i've committed
to the bit of
guessing at least three pronunciations
every time i say it
i don't know if i'll do that next time
but is what i'm doing this time whoo
you get a huh
[Music]
which character did you play in once on
this island by the way okay
so um
i played a couple um because
uh the way we had it was
the um the
gods and um
the romantic leads
whose names i am now uh daniel
and timoon um were the only fixed
characters and everyone else um even if
you were playing a named character
was also in the chorus so i did
chorus work for a bunch of it but as far
as named characters
uh or characters with you know distinct
lines
i played tauntaun julian and
daniel's father um who i don't even know
if he gets named
that said like we cut the song the sad
tale of the bazones
so i didn't get a song as him um but i
did get um
a couple of little singing bits i got to
do as tonton julian which was fun
and i enjoyed it um again i
wouldn't i wouldn't play it now but at
the time i would have really loved to
have played
papa gay um i would have really enjoyed
that
um ague would have been fun too although
we ended up casting
um i say we i wasn't in charge of
casting or directing but
the directors ended up casting actually
a woman to play ague which worked
better than you would think
so yeah anyone who doesn't know that
show
i've just thrown a bunch of of names
that mean nothing to you
i should wrap up soon um
because if i don't i'm gonna pour
another drink and then that'll just be
that'll be bad like i know you'd have
fun
but it'd be bad it it it
it would go bad uh just got your book a
couple of days ago and 50
of the way through and really enjoyed it
oh
thank you time lord rowan that's really
wonderful
um as cheesy and as slightly
scummy as it makes me feel to say um
if you enjoyed it i hope you'll review
it um
on goodreads where i'm i'm getting a
decent number of reviews but if you got
it off of amazon
i need more reviews on there um
so ah
are you afraid of the dark uh eerie
indiana or tails from the crypt keeper
did you like any of these growing up
which did you like best i didn't know
any of those
growing up um tales from the crypt i
like i
found in my late teens and it's got some
enjoyment out of that but the rest of
them
um like i heard of but and didn't know
anything about
who's mr buck scott buck yes yes chris
scott buck show runner of
the last four seasons of dexter
and of iron fist
and of um
[Music]
the inhumans i did i wanted to say the
immortals but i knew that was wrong so i
stopped myself
but now i've just told you what i almost
said that was wrong
so now you know i was fumbling and
stalling for time
because i couldn't think of the thing
and i'm hoping
now that maybe you think it's endearing
or maybe i just look like i don't know
what the hell
i'm talking about which would in fact be
accurate about half the time i don't
but i find if you can keep talking long
enough
people will forget the fact that you
didn't know what you were talking about
because they assume that if you really
don't know what you're talking about
well they're gonna stop talking at some
point but if if you just don't and
eventually you can hit on something that
you do know what you're talking about
they'll forget the part where you didn't
know what you were talking about
you know what i mean
would you refer to us as a term of
endearment um
i don't um i don't have
a uh a collective term for
my subscribers or my patrons and i
like i know some youtubers do i know
that um like for instance um
[Music]
uh dominic noble um you know calls them
his beautiful watchers
and things like that and like i do think
that's cute i don't think that's a bad
thing but like i could never
think of something that i really liked
for that um and then like i am
circling back to an earlier topic i am
uh
i'm in the kink community enough
uh to uh not
take the bestowing of honorifics lightly
and i will leave it at that
said the pride month is almost over yeah
yeah
i really did whoosh by um i thought we
were the council i mean you are
you're like you are that is that is the
closing
that is how i i try and present as much
as possible but you know like that
it the council is very formal uh as a
as a designation and it is kind of
i think sweet when um
youtubers have a more affectionate term
for
their followers like um jimmy dodgers
calls his
followers uh spuds no i i do think
that's cute but
did you ever watch sense8 i liz and i
just started trying to watch it again we
had started it like
years ago got distracted did something
else and we've
come back to it we are that's become our
new watch together show
so hopefully we'll get through that it's
probably going gonna be slow
though like you need to realize when we
do
um
uh when we do shows that we watch
together it's like one maybe two
episodes each time we see each other
so like it's gonna be slow going
um i should wrap it up i see a bunch of
people like bowing out and
and i i should i should uh wrap it up
i know exactly what you're talking about
oh good geek filter good somebody does
that's good because i don't um
vera's voluptuous vixens
uh tempting but like i know not everyone
who watches me wants to be perceived as
voluptuous
so that that doesn't quite work and
vixens is
a uh sadly gendered term
uh have you seen invincible nope i have
not
oh jeez a whole bunch of questions
coming all right i'm gonna i'm gonna try
i'm gonna try and
go through these uh knowing it was his
final role
james stewart's speech at the end of
five will goes west is kind of emotional
valid i'm trying to get uh streamers
attention
i think they're ignoring me but they
claim they aren't have any sage advice
i really don't i mean give them the
benefit of the
doubt as best you can because especially
if the
chat is really active and going by fast
is hard to keep on top of
um that's that's about all i've got
would you two ever watch glee together
[ __ ] no
uh cats are last christmas gun to your
head
cats is more interesting so i guess that
one all right
we're done uh
so thank you very much for
your time your indulgence
um this was fun this
you know no plan don't know what i'm
doing gonna ramble
gonna hydrate um but thank you for
tuning in
i hope you had a good pride month
and i hope you have a good time after
that
like i said unfortunately there will not
be any twitch streaming
tomorrow um the
review of loki will still go up though
probably not till later in the day
unless i get really lucky
um but like the the normal release of
stuff should not be disrupted but like i
am
things are probably going to be quiet in
the break room for a little bit because
i'm just having a hard time
getting on top of stuff
anyways thanks so much for tuning in
have a good night
you are beautiful you are valid you are
loved
you are the council i just drink through
the meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
mccabe